[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to the
Quickstart for Cloud Bigtable.
On the Bigtable page,
select Create Instance.
Under Instance Name,
type Quickstart Instance.
This should auto-populate
the instance ID for you.
For this Quickstart,
select Development
as the instance type.
Under Zone, select us-east-1c.
Then click Create.
Once the instance
has been created,
open Google Cloud Shell.
And after it's initialized, type
in gcloud components update,
followed by gcloud
components install cbt.
Then insert the project
and instance information
into the CBT RC file.
We can now create
our first Bigtable
by calling cbt
createtable my-table.
We can confirm its
creation by typing cbt ls.
We will now create a new family
for the table and call it cf1.
We can confirm its creation
by typing cbt ls my-table.
Now we can use the
cbt set command
to set a key value
pair in our table,
and use cbt read to verify
that the key value was
stored properly.
Congratulations, you've
completed the Quickstart.
[MUSIC PLAYING]